[Music]
whoa all right five four three two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sake on on simulation
we bring on different global leaders
that are building important futures and
we distill and disseminate all their
complex future that they're building to
you in relatable and fun ways so today
we're featuring mark esse Finch thanks
for coming on to the show thanks for
having me appreciate it
so mark s is all about inclusive health
yes inclusive health public health tech
that I'll get into and also a little
blockchain on the side but very excited
about the space especially watching
health space I love how you were just
like a little blockchain on the side
like a cool blockchain on the side it's
like it's like a spice that you add to
the dish yeah okay because blocking is
really important in health and we're
gonna talk about that and we're in talk
about equitable health inclusive health
so you ended up doing masters in public
health I did a George Washington
University I did I was on the med school
track I think like most people
interested in biology or health or
science and was actually I mean on you
know on the pathway towards medical
school for a very long time through
college and even after college my first
job out of college was one of a camera
right here by the way oh yeah you have
one right here too just the heads out so
yeah after after college I ended up
working at UCSF as a clinical research
assistant because I really wanted to get
into kind of like the the academic and
research side of medicine and
and you know what that life looked like
the academic practitioner because I was
very serious about practicing medicine
and I was very passionate about health
but you know you can't expect life to go
the way it is and sometimes life gives
you little nuggets of opportunity little
windows of opportunity and I always walk
through them that's my kind of motto in
life cuz you never know what's gonna be
on the other side if you don't like you
can always come back so you wanted to
make it health more applicable to
people's lives as quickly as possible I
did I did and I still love the idea of
treating healing but I realized I could
do that differently than what medicine
or traditional medicine was doing and
that really is treating groups
communities populations and and that to
me was just really fascinating because
it was a different way of looking at
health one that we don't do a lot of in
the u.s. or even just like in in general
we don't look at the social fabric in
different pockets of demographics
because we are so very convinced that
individualization of everything is the
most important thing but when we think
about the social fabric in little
pockets of demographics that are low SES
that we can actually be like hey what
different types of ways can we mint the
fabric in that area to help the group in
that area and therefore help the
individuals really and I think we we
know this but we don't execute it well
and that's everything in life is
integrated and so other countries kind
of have taken that practice or that that
concept and put it into practice much
better than we have I think we we know
that we're slowly getting there but we
still have a lot more work to do and so
harder with 320 million people than with
5 million people
it absolutely is we are also a younger
country then then you write the most
other
countries and we're also not a
homogeneous country oh yeah so we're
dealing with a lot of history we're
dealing with a lot of chasms and issues
and inequities built in through that
historic fabric so it's a lot of
unlearning and undoing in order to move
towards the future so it's it's hard I
like how your mindset is like I can do
the doctor route and I can do the
one-on-one healthcare route and that's
really important and there's a lot of
people doing that and that's crucial but
then there's also the 10,000 foot view
of the public health ecosystem and how
we can impact people on a grander scale
in that sense and it's good to have your
mind in that sector impacting people
it's a fascinating space and I think you
know the more people dig into what that
means and of course we'll go for what
public health is and what social
determinants are which are big part of
let's do that right now social
determinants public health let's do it
yeah sure so the social determinants of
health which is what my fund focuses on
is really about the social cultural and
political aspects or barriers or factors
however you want to call it that go into
affecting your health and so you know
traditional medicine and I say
traditional medicine because medicine is
now starting to incorporate more social
determinants into treatment and practice
traditional medicine really looks at the
body so how do we treat the body as a
container right so when you go to your
doctor they're really trying to get you
back to a homeostatic level that for
your body right certain temperature
certain heart rate
but what public health does is that it
looks at the environment of which the
container lives in which have a lot of
impact on your health totally so if
you're homeless chances are you're gonna
be so healthy you're sicker
you don't have access to services you
want to have access
to nutrition house malnourished yeah
right so financial health is really
important when it comes to health so is
education mm-hmm the more you know about
how things work the more you can avoid
certain foods or Caviar's you know the
more you can practice other healthy
behaviors like you know vegetables in
your diet and not smoking and etc or
looking both ways before you cross the
street that's someone someone taught you
that right your mother or your caretaker
caregiver when you were a kid taught you
to look left and right before you cross
the street that's a public health a
public safety you know educational and
there's a couple of these nuggets that
are not communicated that well to people
and so like what are some other lis what
are some like other cool nuggets that
like we don't even like that we
shouldn't be thinking more about or even
teaching kids about regarding their
public health yeah so you know one thing
that a lot of people don't associate
with direct impact to health and when I
say direct impact to health I mean like
the chances of you actually getting the
flu hmm the chances of how quickly do
you recover when you're sick how often
are you sick
those types of diseases are yet like
really direct tangible things right
systemic racism or systemic inequities
built into our social systems have
direct effects on how healthy you are
said the direct effects on how often you
get the flu mmm how quickly you recover
from illness these these direct tangible
things have really strong correlations
and in public health studies to things
like systemic racism or poverty or low
education I mean like very very strong
correlation absolutely and so you know
we have to think about well well that's
oh those are two two points that are
really hard to connect for a lot of
people and so let's talk about like
systemic racism and health right
why would experiencing racism or some
other cut type of prejudice
racism right to be classism it could be
class classes it was huge thing in this
country and around the world can be any
type of prejudice right there is a
response in the body called
fight-or-flight total it's what we all
know right so it's a rush of hormones
it's a rush of hormones in the body that
gets you ready to either fight a it's a
it's some sort of attacker or some sort
of hazard that you're being faced with
right so something or someone is
attacking your body goes into
fight-or-flight mode and you are either
ready to fight or to run this is like a
very carnal right sympathetic nervous
system exactly this is a very carnal
response in lots of animals right not
just us
and so cortisol is totally is the
hormone that's released in order to prep
your body for that right now when you
experience little micro traumas every
single day for years on end you're
essentially happiness a certain level of
cortisol flowing through your body an
elevated level of cortisol flowing
through your body all the time right and
cortisol can have really damaging
effects when it's been when that cord is
also being washed over organs and and
and throughout other places in your body
over and over again for long periods of
time it actually can degenerate lot of
tissues it has other negative effects
and so when you're talking about how
strong is the body to defend itself from
disease or to heal itself from disease
well if you ever already have a
compromised container then you can
imagine how hard it would be to keep
yourself healthy or to get yourself
better if you are sick and to maintain
health right so so that's that's one
social determinant that a lot of people
don't think about when they think about
total health and
I would say the social cultural
political and I say political because
policy has a lot to do
yeah how healthy we are that has that's
about 80% of total health meaning that
80% of the choices that you make the
conditions you live in the policies in
which we live under is 80% that's 80% of
how well we can keep ourselves healthy
the other 20% are like access to
services right senior doctor taking her
medication you have a really good
graphic actually I do for this yeah I do
look we can pull it up let's take a look
at it because I think it's good to have
a visual for it sure all right so where
were we we were right
denied yeah Sophie if we go let's go I
went on to social determinants actually
it wasn't the other one that I think
that I had open it might have been he
might not be in this one but we can go
back cuz that last one was good too yeah
there might be this Ward graph but man I
only work with professionals haha yeah
because we had it's okay go ahead yeah
so I think maybe we could do up and down
arrow okay so we so here this is a good
graphic yeah so these are really good
examples I forget what this type of
graph is called like a it's a word
loaded graph yeah that is what it's
called right and so when in a word graph
the weight data points are represented
are obviously with words but the size of
the word it conveys the impact yeah of
that certain data point right so these
are all the things that make up social
determinants of health health I'll say
at least most of them not everything
yeah you can see like you know what are
some of the biggest words up there so
justice yeah possibly ethnicity
disparities right health service is a
big one obviously but poverty race
disparities ethnicity health policy
health promotion right this is this goes
to education health promotion how
educated are we about the things that
affect health and how we can protect
ourselves what are some of the small
ones sexuality
what is that developmental origins of
disease so like you know how disease is
develop cancer is pretty small on there
which is surprising so the law genetics
is the smallest look yeah we're looking
at looking at this it thanks Ron sorry
it's all good looking at this it makes
me really one thing that we talk about a
lot on the show is the importance of
nuance and understanding all the
variables that go into difficult
conversations because we don't like to
keep things binary healthcare should be
this way or that way one or zero done no
like look at all of the different
variables they charge that way under our
fee for service system by which we can
which we'll get into later but you're
right it's not binary at all it's it's
you know it's everything is relates to
one another and very nuanced and dynamic
ways and I think this is why we are
still learning about health and this is
why everyone says health is so
complicated it's so complicated because
they're in between each one of these
factors are a million different dynamic
points that we're still trying to figure
out yeah right but it's not impossible I
think where we can make a lot of headway
isn't really thinking about these social
determinants of health because we
haven't in the past when it comes to
health care I think something important
to mention here is that in the u.s. in
heavily white areas there are social
injustice --is that occur to people that
are not
and the same things applied in other
parts of the US and other parts of the
world where white people are a minority
where white people are the ones that
have the issues of racism as in there is
racism happening to white people where
they're not getting the best access to
health care as well because of the
different all these different
determinants of health absolutely yeah
absolutely I think that's a
misconception too in the US
I only say in the US right and I don't I
can't speak for any other country not an
expert in other countries but in in the
US by volume most people of poverty are
Caucasian by volume mm-hmm it's a
misconception that people of color make
up the majority of people in poverty mmm
but it's not if you look at the sheer
numbers it's it's Caucasian citizens
it's poverty less than a thousand a
month or something um the you know what
they changed the federal poverty level
recently and so I'm not exactly quite
sure what it is but it's at or below the
federal poverty level so he defines
poverty extreme poverty would be like 50
purse yeah 50 percent below or whatever
that yeah of extreme yes so and it's
also interesting across the world just
how a thousand a month here begins to
get you a lavish lifestyle in another
place it's just very interesting yeah
like dynamic for economies so so so um
so social determinants so this has a lot
to do with multi variability and just
how do we actually build a better social
fabric which is a lot of what we talked
about on the show and so now you you had
been you had been mentioning there was
another word that you used with public
health what was the other word they used
so public health tech maybe and then
there and then you had another one I
forgot I forgot it was it no worries
worries so what we what we do social
determinants was the other one which
really just that's social determinants
of yeah that's what we just looked at
okay the social factors that go into
health public health tech on the other
hand
huh is a is a term that my partner and I
coined as far as we know and please if
there's anyone out there in the
interwebs if anyone else came up with
this beforehand or if anyone else is
working in this dear God please get in
touch with us because it's very lonely
being the only very very lonely I'm mark
asset P to health CEO please email me so
public health tech is essentially well
the definition we came up with is a tech
or tech enabled service that's either
preventing the onset of disease so
prevention preventive health or
addressing the needs of we can we put
medically well vulnerable populations
sometimes for investors who aren't
familiar with the space we have to say
medically vulnerable populations but
we're talking about vulnerable
population yes and what does this mean
what does this mean
it means that we're building solutions
tech solutions to support the 99% is
really what it means there is an entire
market out there now I'm going to switch
to the business side not only is
building our building solutions for the
99% just a good thing socially right but
it's a huge business case so when you're
building diverse products and services
for diverse populations there's actually
evidence that shows that you not only
build better products so just you know
better made but that your revenues are
higher there's a Deloitte study on this
on diverse teams and the joy and the
revenues that they've generated
interesting this is something that I was
looking for like four months ago when I
was hosting Jordan Peterson is that
diverse teams produce higher revenues
absolutely and better products yeah well
I understand the better products because
the better products is like if you're
trying to make a product for for a
diverse population if but there's only
one group of people making the product
it's not gonna be as obvious all right
that one seems a little more obvious but
then the increasing around is really
interesting I'd love to see that the
wait study and pass that along to I
would be happy
to send it to you it's a very famous
study it's been around for for a number
of years I can't even say it's new like
it's been around fruits I first learned
about the study and other studies around
diversity and inclusion I was at the
Cape or Center for Social Impact and
they do amazing work on diversity and
inclusion in tech why we should have it
how we can get there and and sort of the
methods that we can employ to do it I
don't think they're horrible words like
a lot of people make them out to be
diversity inclusion yeah it's absolutely
not
yeah but I also think the opposite is
also true of like being so pro diversity
inclusion that we don't hire people
based on a meritocracy is also not as
good either right there there's there's
a misconception that considering
diversity inclusion means you're
sacrificing meritocracy that's myth
that's completely a myth and so there
are a number of companies that have
sprung up in that area you know that are
doing hiring that are doing product
development that are taking out little
pieces that could cause unconscious bias
in order to produce better meritocracy
right so hiring blindly bleak meaning
identification identify our blind yeah
exactly only the work experience is
exactly or if like if it's a tech
position then only your code speaks for
itself right yeah more than then this
was also with I thought the symphony
hiring was really interesting they just
put a barrier up and you couldn't see
you could just hear the music exactly
that was that is the inspiration for a
lot of the units and services now on the
market for tech and all of a sudden now
people are you're seeing that actually
there there is a greater amount of
people of different group identity being
hired because yeah there is a barrier
now between it's a it's a closed it's a
blind hiring it is but and I think these
teams are actually finding that they can
build much faster much more efficient I
think they're finding that their
products and services are more
label their client base or to their
consumer base and now they're
experiencing better returns and so that
this is this is something that we not
only see in the market have evidence for
but it's definitely something that we
push when it comes to inclusive health
and when it comes to public health tech
preventative health population health
social determinants because this is an
area that is just right for innovation
for entrepreneurs for investors for
payers for anyone that manages employees
or deals with large populations in this
area are wanting needing asking for
solutions to help manage them and this
is both for for both for vulnerable
populations as well as for just the
overall 99 percent absolutely and you
know low income is vulnerable that's a
vulnerable population yeah yeah that's a
vulnerable population anyone is you know
managing a chronic disease is a
vulnerable population obviously children
are vulnerable population this is a lot
this is a much much bigger market than
the San Francisco market you and I are
used to right Tech has been innovating
for itself over and over and over again
we need to start expanding the people
and we innovate for it just it's a
business opportunity it's a it makes
business sense it's an interesting way
to put it so it's like the people at the
absolute top of the socioeconomic status
which are a lot of the engineers and
designers that live here are then
innovating a lot for the top one or five
percent and so if their attention can be
can be aligned with good incentives in
like public health tech and other areas
then all of a sudden we can maybe get a
lot more innovation for these other 99%
of people especially in the u.s. yes and
there's a lot of money to be made
there's a huge business case there's a
business case and so the question that
we get you know my partner and I that we
get from a lot of potential investors
are well we like the story we want to
get involved but there's
Vanessa Masons that's my partner she's
whips March teaches me everyday cool
just a very sharp lady and I'm very
lucky to have her as my partner don't
you have you too
I'm sure she would say that but I think
I'm luckier what so I'll give you an
example when people say okay that's
great we want to get involved but who
pays people that are low-income we don't
like how do they pay they can't you know
pay for you know high-end products and
the answer is they're not paying like I
mentioned before it's the institutions
that are managing them that are paying
because they are required by law or by
something else in order to manage this
these groups I'll give you an example
it's kind of a semi health example there
is a company that keep our capital
invested in early in the early days
called Venice stream and they help
patient a Medicaid they qualify right so
there's streamline the process it's very
very easy now Walmart I think some years
ago changed their policy to where many
of their workers in their stores weren't
didn't qualify for health insurance
because they didn't work enough hours
and so obviously this is a that was a
really bad situation we wish Walmart
would have just paid for their you know
health insurance or care but if that was
the way that you know they were going to
form their policy then been a stream had
a solution and so Walmart ended up
contracting with been a stream in order
to provide health insurance through
Medicare to to their employees through
been a stream so they would give them
their package they would say like we
don't have employer supported health
insurance but
we're gonna connect you with ministry
and so Walmart paid been a stream for
that service mmm right Walmart I mean if
I know I know
thousands of entrepreneurs I wouldn't
want a Walmart account right I mean they
that's a great client to have if you're
building on your business and so Susan
and then a wall so then Walmart will pay
Bennis stream and Benes stream will
connect those employees to Medicare
exactly okay and then that streamlines
the process for Walmart and Walmart's
and not already providing Walmart
doesn't feel as bad that they're not
providing health insurance for them
because they know that their employees
have an option but okay but yet and then
and then these employees can get
government based government insurance
government issued insurance now why is
that why do you need a service like that
there are a lot of people to qualify for
Medicare and even Medicaid that don't
connect with it for one reason or
another because the process is too
cumbersome because they're an uneducated
or can't access I don't know a computer
or something just very trivial to
connect to those services it's not easy
enough it is definitely not easy anyone
tells you that Medicare Medicaid is easy
is line straight to 13th it's very it's
a very complicated service it's a very
complicated program and anything that we
have said is great
anything anything and that's really what
tech does best right what tech does best
is that it makes things faster and it
makes things more accessible okay any
any tech solution out there did you
those two things mm-hmm and so when
we're talking about public health tech
we're talking about the vertical that
piece of Health Ventures invests in the
conceptual part of the technology is
actually not new it's been around for
many many years which is a good thing
right because you want a solution to be
built off of years and years of evidence
years and years of programming practice
and that's what these entrepreneurs do
what they do differently is that they
make it faster
is this one of the companies in the in
the deck that you highlight so we have
several yeah so if you go back to yeah
this is a good one so I'll highlight
almada I won't do everything just yeah
but Amada is a very great example
they're an example of a much more mature
company obviously we haven't we they
were around before we even started in
the fund so it you know they're not an
arbor fully we wish but we have worked
with them in the past they're a great
company and what they did is that they
took the diabetes prevention program
it's a very famous program a ten year
longitudinal study on diabetes
prevention what was that what did they
do to prevent diabetes and the problem
with them it was a number so what they
found at the end of the study it was an
NIH sponsored study but they found at
the end of the program is that if you
did these I think it's like six or seven
things lose seven percent of your lose
seven percent of your body mass change
your diet exercise I think it was like
three times a day for thirty all right
three times a week excuse me for thirty
minutes then don't quote me on that
it's been a while since I've seen it but
if you did these things then there was a
high chance that you would not develop
diabetes for pre-diabetic
so it was it was seems like that common
sense yeah it's common sense right but
now if there's evidence a ten-year study
on it yeah that's compelling yeah it's
weird that people need to have a
longitudinal study to know that a little
bit of exercise and healthy eating will
help them lose weight and therefore not
onset diabetes exactly and yeah things
that are common sense we don't really
there they are
mm-hmm we don't really know their
digital behavior change program so there
are digital therapeutics companies yeah
so what they did I'm just a story what
they did is that they took that study
and they digitized it mm-hmm so they
created a platform for it they there is
an accompanying app there was there's a
wearable associated with their program I
think they also have like
case management workers so it helps you
get there it helps it helps it helps
streamline the process it helps it it
makes the process faster I'm more
accessible and more accessible right
yeah and so now they're providers the
doctors can access that data online
yeah the time that it takes to
communicate or to get that real-time
feedback is a lot quicker that's what
they did very successful at it
really there's our 15 min timer thank
you Ron ooh here we go it I was just
thinking about the snapchat streak so
there's like those daily streaks on
snapchat the day that you talk to people
and I was like why doesn't why aren't
there like you know Omata has you know
your daily streak with with we're
checking in for your healthy eating and
checking in for your exercising for
people that want to use something like
that yeah so this is good so this is
these are good examples maybe we we
talked about kind of did a little bit of
that spending so obviously like you
talked about the opportunities massive
for the amount of people that don't
actually have adequate accessible access
as well as on technology yeah about the
opportunity if you go back to this to
the opportunity slides just to quantify
them for folks let's do it okay okay so
yes so this is the opportunity I'm
talking about so if you're talking about
the value of preventative services by
2020 this is an almost one hundred and
forty five billion dollar market there
is money to be adness now secondly oops
how many people are affected in this in
this group that we're talking about now
this is just the u.s. person a US and
people with just adults with just one
chronic disease risk factor but we know
typically they have more many people
have more talking about whom 14 million
people and growing and that's just
chronic disease
you think about everything else that
comes with vulnerable populations you're
you're talking about you know you're
talking about more infections at a
higher frequency you're talking about
readmissions you're talking about
non-compliance Dominica you know you're
talking about a lot of things this is
just one small area I mean it's not
small at all but it's one part of the
opportunity it's a huge opportunity but
you know I think one thing I do want to
mention yes is why do we create a fund
around this why do we care about this
and it's because of the way that our
health system is moving in towards and
so right now right now we are in a
fee-for-service mm-hm
helpers value-based care and we're
moving into a value-based care model and
so for you know for those watching a
fee-for-service essentially means if I
treat a youth if I treat a broken arm
I'm gonna treat you for every single
thing that I use to treat you with as
opposed to I'm the payer or there's a
payer who pays me the provider treat
your broken arm and they say I'm gonna
give you a hundred bucks fix the army
you can do it what the $25 is fine if
you use all hundred fine doesn't matter
to us but you have a hundred dollars and
so if I can treat that broken arm for
$25 I can keep the cost savings
maintaining a level of care right yeah
you have to maintain a standard of care
but if you can do it for cheaper so it's
an incentive program hugely and so the
business models have come out of that
like they keep like accountable care
organizations bundle payments Hospital
value-based purchasing and now even more
recently if any readmission under 30
days gets fined possibly gets fined if
they have a certain amount of
readmissions in their 30 days that's
yeah these these types of incentive
structures are very interesting because
it's a decreasing the amount of
corruption in the healthcare system as
well absolutely it's a pervasive
incentive system the fee-for-service
models super pervasive it essentially
rewards sickness
yeah rewards sickness young and so with
the value-based care model we're
rewarding healthy outcomes so when we're
talking about social determinants and
everything what exactly is going to help
providers keep their patients healthy
and out of their office so they can reap
those savings it's social determinants
of health there's got to be some carrots
and some sticks at the same time so like
the the the the stink example would be
like if you have more than the thirty
percent of patients are readmitted after
a month and there's a stick there's a
punishment there's a fee but then the
carrot is is if you have lessen or if
you have less than 30 percent
readmissions then we'll give you a
reward yeah yeah so now folks are going
to be looking for ways to manage
patients better to have better health
outcomes to keep them out of it out of
their office and not having to treat
them and spend more and more money the
way we do that is with social
determinants of health we create
solutions to help people take care of
themselves outside of the physician's
office outside of the hospital and so
this is where my partner and I focus
moves to text services so the idea is
that the public health tech can can
analyze social determinants and then
help people within an ecosystem of their
social determinants to assist with
value-based care absolutely so the
technology is coming out of this side
it's gonna be distributed administered
or advocated by the folks operating here
because they're taking advantage of this
new incentive yeah yeah so that's that's
great this is a thought process that we
had this is we work backwards this way
yeah and my partner both me public
health professionals I moved into tech
understand this space very well it can
make those connections
now we're talking about block chains on
the scene now right good I'm glad we're
talking about something good I want to
make sure we touch on this so and here
comes watching enter blockchain
blockchain has some real potential to
address a lot of the pain points that we
see everywhere here actually and so what
is blockchain do what is blocks and
blockchain isn't it's an immutable audit
trail it's an audit trail you cannot
change right at its basic level in
decentralized and decentralized and you
know you can also write in smart
contracts sometimes right so a lot of a
lot of the health service model much of
the paper service actually a lot of
value-based care as well is a lot of
checking and verifying
checking and verifying that you say who
you are yeah and that you are eligible
to get these services we hire a lot a
lot of people in this country to do just
that
so blockchain with smart contracts built
in now we can start automating that it
can happen extremely fast it can take
out the middleman I mean it can
essentially take out a lot of middlemen
banks potentially even insurance plans
if we're thinking track lis enough or
should say not sure ins pants by Obama
managed care groups and so so that's
once some of like the easiest you know
use cases for for block chains supply
chains are another one right that is
completely based on an audit trail
that's another use case but we're really
excited about what it could do for
social determinants of health one of the
ways one of the things that's very hard
to do right now is to track horrible
populations
totally because they pop up here in a
community health center they pop up in
this hospital some months later they pop
up there and then they're accessing a
whole set of community community
benefits that folks like hospitals and
the kaisers and the Aetna's have no
access to or can't even find it's very
siloed and it's very difficult to get
and so you know with identifiers like
let's say biometric identifiers know we
can start tracking on the blockchain
where these folks are seeking services
how they're living there I just heard a
that just came across a company and you
come
my partner talking about just yesterday
that's gonna be they're gonna be
attempting to use bar chain to track
homeless people so they're like how
they're living where are they where are
they meeting them what do they have on
them what are they all these this is all
these are all things that we need data
on so it's it's everything about the
social determinants so it's like who you
are who your identity is and then it's
all of the different determinants around
you and within you both your biometrics
as well as where you're visiting what
health institutions you're visiting and
then it's making so not only keeping
that on a distributed digital ledger but
then furthermore making it easily
accessible for other public health
institutions to access that digital
ledger pull your data when they need for
being able to see how they can best have
value-based care around you checking in
on you checking in on your biometrics
checking in on your health in general
and then providing some sort of even
like incentive structure around
value-based care both for you with
something like Omata health but also for
them with something like incentive
structures so that they keep you in good
health as well so it's like this it's
like the perfect addition to the
healthcare industry to make everything a
little bit more both decentralized but
also immutable yeah exactly and and the
cultural political and social aspects of
health is where money leaks out of the
health system so imagine if we could
tighten up those holes and keep a lot of
that those dollars you're talking about
reducing the spend which is massive in
health care you're talking about really
making this value-based care system
highly incentivized not only profitable
but the outcome generating positive
outcome generating and blog changes are
a very great solution for that just
because of its decentralization and
ability yep I feel like all these holes
like you said that exists in the
healthcare fabric are about to be slowly
sewn up and I mean we're trying not to
it it is not easy yeah I think you know
at least when I talk about it I try to
connect the dots for people yeah because
I really want them to have that aha
moment you've been doing a lot of doc
connecting a lot of haha this isn't fun
it's my job it's my job trying to get
more investment and more innovation
happening in this space but but you know
let's be realistic like it's it's not
easy health care is a very very hard
ship to move yeah it is it is not
impossible and what I will say and maybe
even what I will end with is that when a
solution takes hold in this market it
stays forever unlike other if there's an
article's demand for it if it's actually
a good one yeah that's just that's how
our regulatory process and how our
health system works I mean think about
think about policies that have been
implemented or standards of practice
that have been implemented that haven't
changed so for example checking for
prostate cancer only recently has gotten
an overhaul and I think we started that
decades ago I mean I mean when things
proved to work and health care it they
stick around stick around awhile and so
I like how a lot of your work has to do
with inclusive health I think that's
like the essence of your work and making
sure that people actually see that
there's a whole huge amount of business
model also that exists in public health
for even low to medium socioeconomic
status groups as well as just sewing up
that those holes in the fabric that
exist especially for low SES moving
forward it's going to be
I'm glad that you have a soapy soapy -
Health has a fund that invests in - yes
these companies yes we started from one
we started with building the ecosystem
we started what's the size of the fund
so the target is 15 million and have you
raised a couple so yeah we have started
raising okay and we are my partner and I
are nose-down working on that good
blockchain we've incorporated watching -
the technologies we're evaluating now
and so that's good really really
exciting we we started off as as a
meet-up believe it or not oh that's
great
yeah we started off as a meeting and now
a fund I love it it and that's how it
grows right it goes from a meet-up
it blows up into more people than you
could ever imagine that turns into a
community that community has needs they
want to build things they want to invest
in things they want to work on things
and that then becomes an ecosystem if it
gets large enough and distributed enough
so we're also we have small team in
Atlanta right now
good oh yeah tomorrow to meet up with
them and and then from that you know you
start to figure out where where the
greatest needed and so after thinking a
lot through it banessa and I decided
that the biggest bottleneck was gonna be
access to funding so so let's get you
guys funded and get you invested into
these companies let's do it anyone
that's interested in any part of P to
help ventures or I'm watching health
we're at CEO space T now but over ear
out and I'm Marco said P to help that's
who awesome all right we have a couple
of simulation questions to run you
through at the very end all right so our
first simulation question that we like
to ask is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
whoa
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world the most beautiful thing in the
world is seeing the joy and the
inspiration that you get from seeing the
joy and someone that you love mmm I
think that is gonna be my answer for
today I have a new niece she's only
seven months and so she's got me
thinking a lot about that question yeah
and I think it changes throughout your
life to what that means to you yes and
so when she was born just watching her
grow up
just watching her just be super happy
and so innocent and just like as far as
things she gets a lot of joy out of just
yesterday with Rach we were talking
about how the aperture for their
happiness and joy and purpose and like
their absorption of this great signal of
the cosmos is just so open yeah and then
like over time sometimes society closes
that aperture yeah seems like periods of
okay it is it is and I've definitely
experienced that yeah so at the moment
right now and it and throughout my life
I've experienced this but you know
seeing someone that you love be happy oh
yeah so great yeah when they're like
just ecstatic yeah you're just like oh
my god I'm feeling you feel so good yeah
so when someone says I'm happy when
you're happy I mean that's a cliche
that's real yeah exactly somewhere real
yeah there's some mirror-neuron action
going on like your feelings you know
mirror touch that's happening yeah and
when you smile I smile yeah there you go
see it's working everywhere yeah it does
it does all right how about next
question is do you think we're alone in
the cosmos no oh hell no no no and I
really want to meet some one of them one
before I die can we hurry up because
look
I want to meet some of them before I die
can we hurry it up wouldn't Facebook
love that forget 6 billion people on
earth we're talking about yeah we gotta
go connect me too yeah us too
yeah yeah well that's the thing see I
can't do I'm not at liberty to talk too
much but you know we don't know exactly
know how benign the civilizations gonna
be that we encounter I'm hopeful I'm
hopeful that there are brothers and
sisters let's see if we can get there
all right and how about our last
question which is do you think that
we're in a computer simulation what do
you think about that Oh God all of our
cousins oh my goodness
well they say ignorance is bliss so if
we are and I am definitely borrowing
that for the matrix
I choose against you blue pill blue pill
the thing is with the red pill once you
eat the red pill you'll want the blue
tail okay so you think we are or not I'm
just ignorance is bliss is your answer
I don't think we are these things a
space reality I do think so yeah okay
yeah okay I'm still going to blue pill
though this don't worry you uh oh yeah
yeah let's get this in sports all right
thank you so much for coming on the show
this is such a pleasure it's a lot of
fun okay I'm glad you had fun
absolutely good let's get more people
talking about public health and
inclusive public health public health
Tech yes yes yeah we need lots of great
innovators and we lost need lots of
great investors and and lots of good
buyers too but yes yeah ultimately I
think it really is gonna change the
fabric about how we live exactly and a
little bit of a blockchain sprinkle
that's half alright thank you everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate if
you guys had a good time make sure to
subscribe join the family write your
comments below we'd love to hear from
you we'll feature you on our Instagram
and on Twitter please do comment below
give us a like share the content with
other people we always say this but go
create with this content go do something
in public health with it either write
about and make a video about it go and
build a company in the field so go
create don't just consume here go create
and join us on patreon we need to make
this sustainable we need to continue
growing this project and impacting more
people with it so do join us there thank
you everyone for tuning in and we'll
catch you soon thanks Ron Vargas peace
[Music]
[Music]